Next game, however,
Fraggles lost for time
from a very good position
so now we do the four practical
Grünfeld in the suit
and good now we have achieved something like this via a move
change here,
so it comes from
okay, he took my knight,
yes now you can then  take it on C6 and
then try to besiege the weak pawn C6
with A3. I would first like to
take away how much is missing so that the
queen can stand comfortably on C2,
so the knight should go either to E4
or to C4, so e4c5 would be nice,
but Black will certainly prevent it
Knight C4 is not bad with the
idea then under certain circumstances knight E5
if it is possible or bishop d2a5
because A5 is also a weak field
yes that is already possible here
another move yes also do the one
I will do it first that
it is already possible  somehow as a precaution in
the corner
I'll take the tempo with
the drugs E4
if he plays seven with it now
you know the only natural field
is now 4 anyway, an interesting move E4
jumper pulls runner F4 gains another
tempo
um and then I come on that  6 purely
good, of course, unfortunately I'm
blunting the bishop here but I can
still move it later
looks actually looks good
yes good heart jumper B6 or F6
knight B6 actually looks plausible
from
the direction of the gut wing
but well you can now do this here
bishop F4
so of course that's what it looks like now  very
cramped from
knight D6 would now
pick up the bishop pair
the idea is now
5 and then you have used
the bishop here as a
blocking figure
the knight moves seven
so that also makes it I was now thinking of B4
so
now with the queen
so and now is  A position has been reached
where the bishop on A8 is really
great. The
question now is what to do with E5,
E5 rook, the 1 rook, me one, A3
of course looks terrible
positionally
for Black,
I'll do that so it always has to
be good, actually
G6 okay  But the air hole is
bad even further the fields
so now I can somehow even play it in such a way
that I don't even have anything
less at the moment it's interesting
so seven tunnels 1 rook which
wins chess as back then in the end the bishop ca
n't I can still do a tempo  yes,
okay,
under certain circumstances, I don't know,
maybe he has to move Tobi 8 now
to the move like, um, of
course, sometimes like a
tone for nothing,
yes, here the whole
opening was a bit difficult with the one with
the isolated pawn that is standing up,
I think  Black should
somehow do C5 and try to
swap it quickly somehow, i.e. the B7.
This constellation is really
very, very critical,
so white probably
also has different options, so yes